Speaker 1: It is indeed the last full day before
the 2022 midterm elections. And what a day it is,
a truly packed program and we are going to be
talking about in significant detail tomorrow
really what is at stake in this election.
But for today, we are going to contextualize
it will contextualize it by looking at some of
the final Democratic and Republican rallies and
some of the final polling as well. And one bit of
polling that came out over the last couple of days
that is particularly disturbing is the degree to
which this country, the United States, has fallen
into a veritable cesspool of conspiratorial
thinking when you really don't need to find
such conspiracies to understand what it is that is
going on in the country. And as is often the case,
conspiracy theories have some kernel of truth
in their origin, but take people very much in
the wrong direction in terms of their beliefs. And
let me make it very concrete for you. A new poll
shows that 44% of voters see a secret cabal
that is controlling the federal government.
When you look at this poll of 1000 registered
voters conducted at the very end of October, you
see that 44% overall. But it's not that dramatic
a difference between Republicans and Democrats.
53% of Republicans, 41% of independents and 37%
of Democrats believe the federal government is
controlled by a secret cabal. The thing about
this is you don't need a conspiracy theory about
a secret cabal. We know that overwhelmingly
government and industry and regulators and
the world of finance are controlled by those very
corporations and the wealthy individuals that run
those corporations. That's it. It's not a secret
cabal. There's no secret here. Okay. These are the
folks who have run things overwhelmingly in the
United States for over 100 years. You could argue,
you know, maybe there was a brief period in
the thirties and forties during FDR when it was
really the government was kind of governing the
wealthy to a certain degree and not even really
completely. The seeking the conspiracy to control
secretly is what is disturbing in particular here,
because you don't actually need to look very hard
for who's really in charge. There was I believe it
was a Princeton study, and we covered it years
ago, which found the legislative desires of
corporations and of the rich are much more likely
to be made into law than the legislative desires
of the average person. So we knew this already.
It's not a secret. It's out in the open. And
where it gets dangerous is that you have myriad
propaganda outlets and politicians and others
who will take the kernel of truth, which
is there are entities and individuals.
Beyond just the average people. Whose desires
are overwhelmingly refracted, reflected in how
the country is run. That's true. And then that's
where you get into shadow government conspiracy
theories. And we've seen every version of this
right now. It's kind of hot with the Republicans.
And Trump has been mentioning at rallies, it's
the Marxists, the socialists and the communists.
He doesn't know what any of those terms mean.
Doesn't know the differences between those two,
those three terms. But he uses them. That's who is
secretly controlling everything. And then if you
think about it clearly, you go and you look and
say, okay, if communists are controlling the U.S.,
first thing we should do is find communists. And
then you go and you don't find any there's no
communists in positions of power in the United
States, so you can very quickly debunk it. But
that's what they're going to. And then you know
the other ones, right? The Trilateral Commission,
the Build the Birds, the Illuminati, the Q stuff.
And that theory about it's part of it's Democratic
pedophiles who are controlling the country. It's
the Jews. That's a classic, as always. So what's
so disturbing about some of this polling is that.
It is true. That not everyone's desires count
equally. Right? Your desires and my desires for
what we would like the law to be don't count as
much as the desires of Apple as brought to
the government by highly priced lobbyists.
That's true. But the secret cabal, which lends
itself to all sorts of xenophobia and racism
and conspiracy theories. You don't need it. It's
all out in the open. And of course, we know that
when you believe in the subterfuge, when you
believe in the conspiracy theory aspect of it,
you often vote in ways that don't really make
any sense because you believe things that simply
are not true. So anyway, that's context to some
degree for how people will be voting tomorrow.